FILLING IN FOR CHAD ARMSTRONG
WHO IS OUT SICK TODAY.
WE ARE HERE LIVE
AT THE METRO POLICE DEPARTMENT
K-9 TRAINING FACILITY,
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE LEARNING
SOME APPREHENSION TECHNIQUES
USED BY THE K-9 UNIT.
NOW, OFFICER HANSON, UH, I WILL
BE PLAYING THE ASSAILANT TODAY.
IS THAT CORRECT?
- YEAH, THAT'S CORRECT.
- NOW, OFFICER HANSON,
I AM PERFECTLY SAFE
IN THIS SUIT RIGHT?
- YEAH, YOU'RE 100% SAFE.
IN FACT, THOSE ARE THE SUITS
WE USE FOR OFFICER TRAINING.
- ALL RIGHT!
WELL, THERE YOU GO.
WELL, KIDS, MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DO NOT TRY THIS AT HOME
WITH YOUR CHIHUAHUAS.
OW! OW! OW!
[bleep]!
GET THIS [bleep] OFF OF ME!
DAMN!
[bleep]!
OH, GOD DAMN!
OH, [bleep]!
WHOO!
OKIE DOKEY.
I AM SORRY...
THAT, UH, YOU ALL JUST HEARD ME
USE THAT INAPPROPRIATE LANGUAGE.
THAT WAS VERY UNCALLED FOR.
- WHEN YOU PANIC LIKE THAT...
- YEAH.
- HE THINKS YOU'RE MORE
OF A THREAT THAN YOU ARE.
- UH-HUH.
- THAT'S WHEN HE'S GONNA
BITE DOWN HARDER.
- OKAY, WELL, I WILL...
MAKE AN EFFORT THIS TIME TO...
REALLY TRY AND BE
AS CALM AS POSSIBLE
EVEN THOUGH IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO BE CALM
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE LION'S DEN.
OR SHOULD I SAY
THE DOGGIE DEN?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
[screaming]
OH, [bleep]!
THIS DOG IS EATING MY JUNK!
HE'S EATING MY JUNK!
NO!
OH, [bleep]!
HE'S GOT MY JUNK!
AGHH! OH, MY GOD!
GET HIM OFF ME!
[happy music]